let's do this let's do this the way
you're used to
hello everybody I'm Nick I'm in this
video
that's the easiest joke I keep making it
for the first two years you're all
laughing so you're to blame
hello everyone how are you doing second
day of NDC
can I have a hell yeah
nice you're awake
yeah I don't know how you're gonna be
after lunch but for now you're good
awesome
so yeah let's go straight into this
topic which is a very interesting topic
for me logging and I want to talk about
the title a bit but before I do that
just in case you don't know me hey I'm
Nick oh wow I can see your faces now
that's nice
um I make YouTube videos I'm a bunch of
other things and I have a podcast
because I just in 30 and that's uh
mandatory
and I also run a platform called Dome
train where I sell my own courses if you
want to master any of those topics I
talk about you can check that out
now
actually wait a second how many of you
know me from YouTube show of hands those
of you who did not raise your hands take
out your phone now and subscribe
now
uh it's free and it makes me feel nice
so okay enough with the cell outside
promotion let's go straight into the
topic
um and I want to talk about the title
for a second because
if you were studying my videos if all of
you have um you know one thing about me
I'm a bit of a
I don't want to say clickbaiter
but I'm pushing it is what I'm trying to
say so me being here and saying hey you
know you're doing it wrong how how do I
know that you are doing this thing wrong
and I'll take a bit of a story I was a
couple of weeks ago actually I was in
Romania
and there was this keynote in a
different conference called.net days
where Rachel Apple worked for jet brain
is great speaker
she had this talk about dog patterns and
how people want you to click on things
and try to convert and she was talking
about uh you know all they will not
allow you to cancel your subscription
and so on or Click by the titles in
general in videos and I thought that
this slide would actually turn to
something like this
wait which you know it's pushing it but
um if you have to know one thing about
clickbait is that it actually works
pretty pretty well so don't hate the
player hit the game
um and obviously this full room
so we're all here to talk about logging
and one thing I have to make very very
clear is that other than just a few
things there is not so much in this talk
that is actually opinionated some of
those things are actually factually
wrong it's not that I think it should be
done a certain way and you're doing it
another way it is that that's how you
should do it and if you don't do it that
way you want to have an issue in your
code
and when I do mention an opinion I will
say that this is an opinion you don't
have to listen to me what do I know
anyway
so
let's talk about what
this talk is not about
this stock is not about any of this so
as I'm gonna show loggers I want you to
raise your hands if you've used are
using or know the following privileges
locally anyone knows what that is yeah
okay not so popular uh SEC okay more
hands here how about Cloud watch cloudws
okay how about application insights
Azure am I right Microsoft yeah
you sell out
how about this one data dog you guys
have money you yeah you don't pay the
bill on this
I I would have a joke about gcp but I
don't I don't think anybody uses gcp so
I'm just gonna skip that
so it's not about any of these Services
which you know I'm taking the piss out
of them but uh
they're all great at least
three of them are
it's about this really this talk is
about the code you write your own code
if you've ever written a line of code
like this like have you ever logged
don't be afraid if you haven't yeah come
on come on yeah I want to be awake fine
because I'm assuming if you don't raise
your hand you've never ridden a single
line of code that logs anything and
that's scary
because when things go wrong you want to
know how that went wrong and where they
went wrong
But ultimately this is about the real
world now
as I'm going to be you know going
forward this talk especially in the
first half of it I want you to stay
awake I'm
honestly not trying to sell you a
performance talk as a logging talk I
promise this is a logging talk
but I also really like performance uh
but what we're gonna see has nothing to
do with performance
um directly meaning the performance
improvements we're gonna see and the
reasoning I'm gonna give you in this
talk is actually a knock-on effect of
doing logging right it is not with doing
logging right because we need the
performance
and ultimately it's just about the real
world
so I want to ask a question another one
uh what is this
obviously this is a line of code that
logs something
what is this more specifically
can anyone shout what is supposed to be
who said
right
let's see what Microsoft says that this
is this is
the message
but it's not it's actually the the
template you write
so let's establish a few things I want
to have a theme going on and you need to
that is the most important thing you
need to understand that this is actually
the template and that it is not the
message the same way that Microsoft
tells you that it is the message
um because every problem or the majority
of the problems actually stem off of
that the idea that many people think
that this thing is the message because
Microsoft tells us is the message and
not the template
so well first Microsoft is terrible
blood naming we're gonna say it over and
over again anyone working from Microsoft
here
uh they're great what a company I love
it
so let's establish the theme of this
talk which is NYX eight logging rules
rule number one
the message is actually the message
template and shall be traded as such and
this talk will explain what that means
but
has any of you please raise your hands
like this is important use string
interpolation when logging
oh okay whoever raised their hand
actually let's continue how about string
concatenation
have our string formatting
you just validated the title all of
these are wrong and we're gonna see why
they're wrong
and let's start with the first one which
is string intervalation now string
interpolation is a fantastic fix right I
absolutely love it
um because when you have a message like
this you know user Nick chaps is just
1030 which is actually true thank you
very much for the happy birthday
um then if you want to parameterize that
you might write something like this and
you know even though this will actually
work you have user plus Nick plus
whatever or name plus whatever Justin
30.
this is fine but it's a bit clanky can
we improve it well we have a few
approaches we can follow in.net the
first one is string concatenation so
string dot concat
um and in case you didn't know what the
compiler will do with this one actually
is lower it and turn it into this
what we can also do is think.format well
you can have an index parameter and then
you can pass them as secondary
parameters and then it will be replaced
into the string and build the string
that you want but in C sharp six I want
to say
we got a really neat feature called
string interpolation which from what I
understand all of you know and love and
it's this idea you just put a dollar
sign in the beginning you have curly
braces and then you can wrap your
parameters and then you don't have to
have the pluses
which can lead into mistakes in fact
looking at this code I do have two
mistakes in my string concatenation
second line I missed a space after user
so very neat feature and if any of you
are doing Java as your main language
then you're still stuck in the second
version of this I'm sorry eventually
they're going to figure it out
now one thing you have to know about
c-sharp as a language in general is that
the weight was shipped for years now in
Windows machines mostly
um really prevented it from being
patched so when the CLR one.net the
thing that actually
um eventually will run your code and it
is a new feature implemented Microsoft
wouldn't really touch the CLR we're
going to touch the runtime because it's
very very dangerous so what they would
do instead is they would take the high
level c-sharp that nice new feature in
this case during interpolation and then
write some magic into a middle step
before the file compilation called
lowering which actually takes that and
converts it into low level C sharp that
you don't have to write which is more of
an elegant approach and it's way less
likely it's going to break a runtime
that needs to be patched
however with net core this is no longer
the issue because when there is a
problem we get those I think it's not
bi-weekly fortnightly once every two
weeks we get some patches some changes
so if there's an issue you can just take
it update your Docker images
and you're good
but because of that perception Microsoft
has really been shipping features with
mostly syntactic sugar in fact the only
two features that we finally got now in
C sharp 11 that are not syntactic sugar
is a generics on attributes which wasn't
possible nowadays and the the fancy
static abstract members on interfaces
amazing features but they did require a
CLR update and string interpolation
having been shipped in C sharp 6 was the
same string interpolation actually is
being lowered from that to string dot
format anyone stuck or still is in C
sharp 9 backwards
and I'm assuming everyone else is this
of 10 onwards
okay no you're just lazy okay cool
if you're still in C sharp 9 and
backwards then that is still true for
you this actually has changed nowadays
and it's not as bad
and we're gonna see that as well but
this is your reality that your string
intervalation is nothing than a fancy
string that format
now why is that bad well
both string.format and string.comcat
have a bit of a similar issue than if
you can spot it
this object already over here these
parameters
this is the bane of my existence if
you've ever worked with code that needs
to be super super fast
this is very problematic but to explain
why this is very problematic I have to
explain to you how c-sharp deals with
memory
so please don't fall asleep
so C sharp deals with memory in two
different ways you have two places where
a memory can be allocated the first one
is a stack the second one is the Heap
next
what are you doing
yeah I promise it's a logging talk it's
a logging talk so stack
let's say we have this method over here
so we have int age we have the good
which is extract and then we have the
point 2D which in this case
um initializes an X and Y random points
in 2D space
and assume that this is a struct which
is very important
what this means is that all the values
in this method can actually be allocated
on a memory area called the stack and
that stack is very local to this method
it's called the stack frame
so that's how this thing would be
allocated now a bit of a asterisk here
they're a bit of like more Nuance if you
want to be very pedantic about exactly
what's happening but fundamentally what
you should know is that this is what
you're dealing with your 30 parameter is
put in a location in the stack then
you're good and then the parameters of
your struct because it's deconstructed
and then put into the stock now the good
thing about this is that everything that
the method needs is local to the method
which means that when you go out of that
method and out of that stack frame that
memory isn't needed anymore now we all
know that C sharp is a garbage collected
language so if you create and
an object it's going to need to be
garbage collected eventually when
nothing points to it however because in
the stack we can guarantee that once
you're out of this area
for something that can be put on the hip
then we can just
de-allocate it without having to garbage
collect we just assume it doesn't exist
anymore because nothing is using it
now the hip is a bit different same sort
of example as before but now assume that
this person is a class and this point to
the is also a class so those are
reference type they're not value types
as we had before which is the two main
types of objects we can have in c-sharp
what that means is that the memory
doesn't exactly know how to fade those
items in the the stack so for that they
sort of cheat and they go down the an
easy route of putting them in an area
called the Heap which is just something
else somewhere else where you can just
have an address imagine it has a
dictionary that says if you want object
55 then that is there go get it
um and what's going on behind the scenes
is that eventually when nothing needs or
has a reference to object 55
then the garbage collector has the clear
to say I'm gonna come in here and say
nobody needs that I'm going to put it
into the bin now even me saying that
that something has to find something in
an area and then do something to clean
it up and deallocate it
um sounds like work and it is a lot of
work in fact
when that happens because of how fragile
the whole process can be
the whole application stops nothing
moves other than the garbage collector
which means that you can really end up
in scenarios where if you have a lot of
memory to clean up a lot of pressure
that's being built you're going to have
this inconsistencies in performance
because your application is pausing or
microposing to clean those things up
so back to how C sharp deals with memory
we have the stack which is value types
can be allocated here so your integers
your structs your your goods and so on
go there then you have local variables
and parameters in in methods they can
also be allocated there because they're
copied into the method and then
maintained in the method
it is incredibly fast like insanely fast
and it automatically disappears when it
goes out of scope like we established
with the stack frame
now
the other thing the Heap is a bit more
interesting because reference types are
always allocated here while in value
types value types can be allocated in
the stack but they also can be allocated
on the Heap and it's just this big pool
of memory and it needs to be garbage
collected which is a problematic part
so boxed values and I want you to to
remember this word boxed values will be
allocated here and if a box value is a
value type which it is a value type then
that's where it's going to end up you're
going to have to do something to
eventually clean it
now anyone has seen this before
how amazing.net is like a billion
requests faster than anything in the
universe
yeah Microsoft made this
but it's independent it's uh yeah it's
an open source uh Benchmark if you've
seen this that is very optimized if you
if you squint it looks like c-sharp but
it's not
but if you want to know how they achieve
this and how.net is actually very very
fast is by removing a lot of the
references you normally would have on
the Heap and putting them on the stack
so and if you want to know more about
that I said I'm done with self-promotion
but I'm not there's an episode on my
podcast talking with Stephen tow which
is a performance Wizard and he explains
all that for detail and I pretend like I
understand what he's saying
now like I mentioned before we have the
concept of boxing which is a problematic
aspect of value types being allocated on
the Heap
I promise this is a logging talk
so back to original example we have this
int age equal 30 and I'm gonna show some
IL code I don't know what it means I can
just vaguely tell you what it means it
basically just says put this value 30
into the stack
and that's that there's no boxing
happening it just it's allocated there
and when we go out of the stack frame it
disappears but then you have this where
we have the same age value 30 but this
is now implicitly converted into an
object the compiler will allow it
because the compiler is smart
ish and the way this will be compiled
into IL code is like this so we still
have this stack allocation but then that
is put into a box using the Box
instruction over here and that process
actually does take time it is not cheap
during that process that value type that
could be allocated in the stack now goes
into the Heap meaning it needs to be
garbage collected as its own individual
value so depending on the pressure
you're running those are some extra
bytes you have to keep track of and
delete
now the opposite can also happen if
you're trying to hardcast an object to
its primitive value the value type then
that needs to be unboxed and that's
another type of process that does take
time and eventually return it
why is that problematic well
we're gonna end up with a lot of garbage
and garbage slows us down that is a bit
of a common thing so we have the big two
reasons we have tons of boxing we're
going back to the logging so if you have
that object parameters array and you
pass value types in there they're gonna
be boxed they're gonna have to be
garbage collected you go on and on and
on and on and that's why we actually I
think in.net it we're getting
um span on iron universe so our
parameters on span
so we can actually prevent that from
happening because you don't really have
much of a choice currently at the way
this is built
and the other problem is a ton of
strings if you ever profile your
application especially if you're doing
logging and especially if you're the
ones that use the raise your hand to say
that they're using string interpolation
on logs then you're gonna see a ton of
strings it's probably the most common
thing you have allocated in your
applications right now
and if it is not you probably have
another problem that you need to sort
out
so more boxing means more hip
allocations more hip allocations means
more work to set and retrieve values
which means more garbage collections
triggered which means more pausing to
clean things up because we said we
cannot actually do anything in your
application if it is garbage collecting
and the other thing is tons of strings
which means more hip allocations because
strings are reference types they are put
on the hip and if you think that strings
are only allocated once even if they
have the same value you are wrong
everyone heard of the concept string
interning
string interning is the idea that a
string is only allocated once on the
Heap and then reused based on the
reference
and that is only true for compile
timestring literals you can also force a
value to be entered but that's not
beneficial so if you keep creating a
string dynamically in runtime you are
creating a new unique string every
single time even if it has the exact
same value and that string reference
type it needs to be garbage collected
so super super problematic now that of
course means more gabs collections to
collect those strings because they have
to be collected and then more pausing to
clean things up
but Nick in C sharp 10 we got string
interpolation handlers and they fix that
anyone knows what strength Evolution
handlers are
cool I'll explain it so
we now have not this thing can actually
be compiled now
um or lowered and then compiled to this
so we went from string dot format with
that problematic object array to this
version so if you ever try to use a
website called sharplab.io to see how
your code is compiled that's what you're
going to see for Strings by default and
that can't change based on different
strings but in this example that's what
we're going to get
and the good thing about this is that
online I should have numbered them the
one before the end you see this generic
int used so generic actually prevents
boxing and if any one of you have been
doing this for more than 20 years I
don't know I haven't
um then you would know that in the
beginning we had constructs like an
array list I think to store objects and
those did not have a generic type and
later we go to list and we fixed the
list to a specific type that heavily
fixed performance will improved
performance because you can no longer
box those values so you don't have to
know what they are to to take them out
of the list
so this will prevent all the allocation
issues that you have with the boxing
side of things but if you're using
string interpolation you are still
allocating one unique string first thing
that you're doing and those strings need
to be garbage collected they will slow
your application down now in something
else you cannot prevent it but you
should know it's there and you should
know that you can prevent in some cases
we're going to see them in this talk so
let's visualize this if I have an
application that just does a log dot
information log
um pair a few thousand times a second
all the time
then my memory for this application if I
profile it will look like this so I have
this Spike of memory all the way until
16 megabytes over here and this is
relative to how much memory pressure you
can tolerate in your application
um and then it spikes and it goes down
and then it spikes goes down spikes goes
down this tool is called dot memory in
case you're not aware of it it is a tool
by jetbrains they do not pay me sadly
but what I want you to take a look at is
if you take a look at this thing over
here at the bottom those are
milliseconds or not milliseconds but
maybe microseconds that your application
is doing nothing but cleaning your
memory
so this can still be a very very
problematic so rule number two I shall
not use string interpolation or
concatenation in the message template
because we established it as a message
template and that can be problematic but
what should I use well
structure logging you should use what
this template was made to be used for if
I go back to the following example
if I have a login.log and I use string
interpolation and I start logging my
application is running and it's fine and
then I'm using application insights to
push my logs I'm going to see something
like this I'm going to get on my
payments with my ID and fail with status
whatever
now in a real scenario you will have a
business place and say oh we had an
incident and we have to get all the
council payments maybe within the time
frame or within the last 24 hours so we
can get back and get the IDS and do
something about it has happened to me
and you might say I'm gonna go here
because I'm very smart I remember I
remember at the end with the status code
and I'm very very smart so I'm gonna go
and say traces where message ends with
canceled very easy sort by date ship it
and I'm going to actually get what I
need
and then the next day comes and they
come back and they say hey no tell me
what happened to payment with idx until
it was canceled
good luck sorting that out if you're
using string Evolution because you're
losing all the information all the
crucial information that you could have
in your logs
now let's do the following let's let's
switch it up a bit I'm going to use the
template as it was supposed to be used
and please don't get confused here there
is no dollar sign in the beginning of
this I'm just using a feature of my ID
which can highlight parameters in
structure logging and say that hey I
have this parameter called payment ID
and this parameter called payment status
and the first one I'm going to pass as
an extra parameter is the payment ID and
the second is the status
and if I do that I have the exact same
experience in application insights but
if I expand any of this individual log
entries watch what I have
not only do I have the computed message
but I also have the original format in
the third line
and then the payment ID and the payment
status as individual parameters or
application insights called the
dimensions that different names for them
but it's the same concept so as long as
you use those templates you can actually
capture parameters it can go even
further you can actually time your
message and get that information as well
you can create Scopes and so on
and now with that in mind you can go and
do something like this you can say give
me the traces where custom Dimensions
dot payment status equals canceled and
assuming you're consistent with that
parameter name payment status then
you're going to get it but it's very
important you have to be consistent and
you especially if you're doing micro
Services you don't just be consistent
consistent within your application but
if this payment status is the same sort
of contract across your obligation you
want to be consistent across your
service across your system the whole
thing
that will make it very easy for you to
identify what actually happened then you
can go further you can use things like
the event ID or even the original format
to
um search for something based on its
message template or you can do other
things like I said event ID any of you
have alerts based on a specific look and
feel of a message so maybe you're using
regex or something to identify a
template that's a very common practice
I'm not saying it's good
but this makes it very very easy because
you don't have to pattern match anything
you just say if the template matches
that then here you go
now you might be saying hey Nick this is
still boxing yes I'm not allocating a
new string every time because now this
is a compile time constant I'm not
Computing it on every request it is
there it is reused it is being pointed
out at the memory and then I'm just
um
boxing the parameters
so the only string allocated for this
operation is the one you see below the
payment with ID now if any further
allocation happens that is up to the
provider if you're using application
inside provider if you're using data dot
provider God forbid great great tool
great tool very expensive
um or anything else you only allocate a
string and that string is very very
problematic and you're not going to have
that issue
the boxing in this case until they
eventually fix the parameters object
array thing you can't really do much but
it's going to hurt you way less than
what these strings can do so rule number
three
I shall use structural longing logging
and give good names to my parameters
I'm using serilog any of you use
cellulug I'm gonna keep doing the hand
thing awesome
so I'm fantastic Library cellular log so
look it's just a login library that did
a lot of things right from the beginning
and it has this very nice concept of a
sync which is basically just a
destination you might want to push your
locks and cereal log you might say does
not actually suffer from all of those
issues
and you would be half right let's
explain why
there's by the way two ways of doing
cellulog the first one is using the raw
cellulog I logger so you initialize your
logger and then you put it as a
Singleton into your di container and
then you reuse that how many of you use
this approach
cool and then you have the other way
which is the sale log dot
extensions.logging package which sort of
hijacks the built-in eye logger and it
adds it as a provider how many of you
use this
cool the first ones are the right ones
but uh I will explain why the second one
is the better approach if you like to
look at your code the first one is the
better approach if you like your code
so let's see how Sherlock prevents log
epoxy because they have the same issue
right but still will be smart they say
instead of having a single method for
log information write logs log error log
critical log and so on they thought what
if we make turnover loads with 10
generic T-Type parameters to prevent the
logging whether that fix the problem and
it actually would because now you have
an N amount of degenerate type
parameters and like we established there
is no boxing if you're using generics
except it doesn't really prevent it
let me explain why and to understand why
when you talk about the log level which
is a very funny thing to look at a very
funny
um enum to look especially for Microsoft
I'm sorry
because that's how they decided they
want to write the log level start with
Trace
it goes to debug information warning
error critical and then they said oh
we did not add none we'll slap it at six
and then what if you want to have one
after this
good luck
while cereal log has the same concept
but they said well why do you need none
to be explicit just make it nullable and
forget about it so Trace in logging in
in log level for Microsoft is basically
verbose debug is debug information so on
warning error and then critical is fatal
is a bit Grim I don't know maybe it was
made by Germans
but I prefer critical
any Germans here
you're hiding
so what is the log level why do we have
this well
when you call log information or dot
information in serolog behind the scene
is what you're going to get is a lowered
an overload that uses log level dot
information which is the log level or
log event level which is how cellular
calls it dot information and then if
you've ever looked into your app
settings or Json because if you haven't
I'm scared then you might have seen by
default this sort of logging area
and it has a top level log level object
and then what called what's called log
categories and this microsoft.asp.net
core by default is warning meaning that
if your logs for your asp.net
collaborations are information or below
so Trace debug or anything else then and
it's not higher than warning or equal to
warning then you're not going to see
them eventually into your syncs whether
that is console whether that is data
whether that is anything
but anything else the default one for
everything else starts with information
now out of curiosity how many of you use
information as the default for
everything else
don't be it's not a trap question
be afraid it is a tough question
but I'll explain why later if you take a
look into log the log method of the
Microsoft blogger they have this easy
enable check over here and if that log
level is not enabled so if you're trying
to push a debug level log with log.debug
but your default is information then
it's not going to do anything with it
because nobody cares about it
that however means that even though we
do not push it into the provider or into
the sink eventually it is still boxing
the parameters before it does this
operation
serilog is actually pretty smart what
they say is I still going to have this
ease enabled check but I am not going to
box these parameters before I know that
I need them so they have the generics on
the outside then they have the check on
the inside and vendor boxing which you
cannot really prevent because somehow
you need to pass those parameters
you can prevent it we're going to see
how
but what you can do on your own logging
situation and again this depends on how
heavy your workload is and how much you
want to optimize it but if you have
something like this you can totally take
that log level that is information and
do something like this and say hey if
the logger is enabled for or if it is
not enabled for information then return
early so you can make a method compile
time can be very tiring to write all
these methods to keep track of
everything but it can actually pay
dividends in memory if you have a lot of
login from a log debug or if your
default is higher and so on
so rule number four I shall prevent
unnecessary boxing for inactive log
levels this is a bit situational and
this is a bit of an opinion but if you
actually care about your application
your memory and if you're in high
frequent scenarios then you can do that
remember memory is contextual it does
not mean the same thing for everyone and
our performance is contextual and I'm
not here to tell you that everyone is
processing 10 000 requests per second
or more
but the good thing is that the.net team
has actually been pretty hard at work
anyone know what a source generator is
nice
so
IL generators is we introduced I think
in.net 5 and what they allow you to do
is basically Mark some things into your
code as this is maybe incomplete or this
could actually use a bit more code but
I'm too lazy to write the code every
single time which is a mindset I very
much like
and why don't we write code that knows
how to write code and implement the rest
of the method
and since we have over here something
like this this whole thing looks like it
can be automated because if you have one
prologue information then why don't we
or log anything then why don't we just
search generate it well it turns out
Microsoft has also problems and they
wrote a log message or logger message a
source generator so what you can have is
in a partial class
in this case partial static class you
can have a public static partial void
you can give it a name and you can say
this so this is an extension on the I
logger and create your log item your
your log operation in this case log
payment failed and then you can just say
that the log level for this thing is
information and then the message is
payment with ID and so on this is a
message template they had the chance to
fix it but they chose to be consistently
wrong than half right
which I like actually because that will
be confusing so you know not too mad
about this
and then you have the log payment error
information the log payment error
extension method which you can use in
your application so
the same log entry as before now looks
like this and we still have the event
name the event ID at original format we
have the payment ID and the status we
don't lose any information as before but
we didn't have to write any of that code
why is that awesome it's awesome when
you actually look into the
implementation of what the source
generator will actually do let's take a
look at that
I know it's going to be a lot of code so
let me just point you here the first
thing you need to know here is that the
log is enabled for your log level is
added by default Microsoft Technologies
there is no point in wasting your time
with unnecessary checks and moving
forward so the first thing they do in
the search generator and this is not
configurable is hey can I do I actually
need to do something about this log and
if I don't do nothing go back go away
but if I do need to do something then
I'm going to call this log callback
and what this log callback is is a
private static read-only action with two
actually three parameters
um actually Four parameters I logger
good string and exception which is
nullable if you have an exception and if
you remember the parameter methods we
have we have a goal for the payment ID
and we have a string for the payment
status that's what you're seeing here
and that that field is actually
effectively a cast method on how we are
logging it uses a logger message dot
Define method and then it sort of
generates everything around that
what's behind that well this the first
thing I want to show you is that you can
actually configure if you want to double
check the log level but you don't need
to have it in place but
what's very important is that you notice
the absence of any object array or
parameters here that's because the
compile time we know exactly how many of
those we need and we have this new log
values in line four which is a struct
with generics built specifically for
those parameters preventing extra
necessary memory now I totally
understand that this can be extra
overhead in your developer flow so maybe
this is not for everybody
but
if you can you shall consider using
Source generated logos they can really
really save a lot of memory and really
improve your performance
and it's easy you just write a single
line of code the rest of it is written
for you
now
I mentioned the feature before called
string interpolation handlers but did
you know you can actually write your own
custom string depolation handlers
because when Microsoft adds something
new they tend to actually open it up for
everyone to use
which you know depending on the
documentation can actually you know you
might shoot yourself on the foot but
if you're careful you can actually get
clever with tooling you can do the
following we said that that's the
default behavior of having a string
interpolated string and then lowering it
into the default interpolated Handler
but default implies that you can have
more and that is true I can actually go
here and I can make a refract I can call
it logging interpolated string Handler
and I can just slap the interpolate
string Handler attribute and that makes
it an interpolated string Handler which
is a very hard word to say consistently
so excuse me
and then you can do whatever you want in
there in this case I'm just cheating and
I'm reusing the default one and use that
as sort of a store to eventually return
my own stuff what does that mean well it
means that I can actually Implement my
own methods to append it formatted and
append all the other parameters
but there is no interface that it uses
like basically just duct typing so you
have to be very careful and match the
name but I can do something like this
with a custom interpolated Handler I can
say append formatted use the generic T
type parameter and then use the color
argument expression attribute that can
point to another parameter the message
to get the compile time value of that
parameter
and if I do that then I can
call the internal Handler the append
formatted and make my own template which
means I can have something like this
which means I can have something like
this eventually so my my front end looks
same the only thing that changed is that
I'm not accepting a string known
information I'm abstracting I'm
accepting a ref of a logging
interpolated string Handler which what
you need to pass down is actually a
string interpolated an intervalid string
I mean
and this will work and if you do that
then you're going to get this into your
logs
which is this
your parameter name will actually be
used you're still keeping those
parameters as separate values but then
you don't have to keep track of
everything and have templates for
everything
this is possible but it is bad and if
you consider doing this I do not
recommend this approach and it is bad
because anything you put into those
Kelly braces at compile time will be
captured and used as a parameter name so
if you do something like this which you
can
then your parameter will be called guide
dot new guide literally the string good
luck filtering
so you want to control your parameter
names you don't want to let it to chance
to to know what this might look like
so
I shall not try to get too clever with
tooling guess who did that and paid for
it
now when I go back to the log level
just a little bit I asked you before how
many of you use information as your
default log level and it was a trap
question and that will get a bit
opinionated so if you want to close your
ears you can
but
when you have a log level like this like
information and then you have warning
here what's going to happen is if I
increase that
microsoft.asp.net core which is a
category it's called The Log category to
categorize a set of logs then if I just
run a single normal aspinical request
then that's what I'm getting for a
single request
that's a lot a lot of strings so that's
why by default we're using warning on
the microsoft.asp.net core category
out of all this the only thing that I've
written here is actually this one
retrieved quote for currencies GBP to
Australian dollars in 32
milliseconds now
if I'm not gonna put you in Blast here
I'm not gonna get you to raise your hand
but if any of you are using information
for things like 8-minute core logs I
want you to ask why because when are you
looking at your logs you're looking at
your logs when things don't go well when
things do go well
what like I've never said I'm gonna wake
up at 9am and you know what I want to do
look at my logs
nothing happened but I feel like doing
it
it's not something you would say but
when things break you want to go and see
how they broke
and some of you raise your hand when I
ask hey how many of you are using
datadog
um brave enough Brave of you to raise
your hand but I want to to pay recently
for datadog and they have the following
payment types
they accept Visa Mastercard American
Express and this one
as a kidney
um it can be very expensive and if you
are a big company and work with their
dog for quite a bit which I used to work
for one then they will tell you that hey
you're over logging this is not supposed
to be what what you're doing uh oh sorry
you're not supposed to be doing that
have you considered raising your default
log level
to warning for your lugs
which is a very weird thing to say but
it makes sense when the only thing
it doesn't make sense if the only thing
you're using is logs but if you're using
metrics as well or some of you might be
using open Telemetry where we're going
into a more in-depth situation then look
for look for you are just a single tool
and you can use more to note replication
is working you do not need to have a big
long string to tell you that things are
okay how useful is this to you it's
probably not so useful you can get
Diagnostics out of this how long the
request took and all that and slap it
into just a data store maybe Prometheus
maybe use graphene to visualize and so
on
you don't need your log level to be so
low in production of course
so in my opinion you should consider
using warning as the default log level
it does not mean that you should have no
information logs you can control the
category if you remember in that
upselling.json file and still have some
information logs but you have to use
them sparingly you don't want to use
everything
it's gonna make your life so much easier
as well if when you eventually start
filtering for your logs and want to see
how your application failed
now
how many of you have heard this quote
before pretty much optimization is the
root of a level
cool
Nick
I believe that the root of all evil is
misunderstanding what this quote
actually means because it is actually
used as an excuse to write bad code that
could be
very good by default
and also to just throw a bit of a
responsibility of knowing how to write
performance code away because nothing
from what I've shown you today
inherently is about performance but I'm
sure some of you will walk out of this
room assuming that this guy just talked
to us for 50 minutes explaining how we
can write fast logs which is not the
case it's how you can write reliable
logs and deterministic logs
so do not assume that this is any
performance anything performance related
but hopefully what I've shown you today
because we did not just look into logs
we looked into boxing memory string
tabulation a bunch of stuff struct you
can use all that knowledge to know how
to optimize when the time comes to
optimize which is very important it's
one thing to say this does not need to
be optimized right now which I very much
agree with and it's another thing to say
okay time time to optimize okay how do
we optimize
and then you know how to optimize and
then you do it
so
I want to end this with
another opinion which is
why do we log why are we doing this well
ultimately
it's all about telling a story it's
about telling a story of how something
ideally failed it doesn't have to be
about how something failed but it
usually is or at least you're looking at
it when the time comes to see why
something filed
and now there's books
and there's good books
now arguably
if you read both of them you might get
the same information from both
but you spend way more time on the first
one than the second
the problem is that we are not with our
logs what we in Greece called laconic
any of you know what this word means
cool I was in Romania again and
apparently they have the same world in
the vocabulary I expected no one to
raise their hand everyone raised her
hand
so
yeah laconic has to do with Spartans not
these ones not these ones these ones the
real ones
I have to censor it
so the Spartans were very very well
known obviously the fighting ability and
being
um fighters from a very young age but
they were also known for being glyconic
which has to do with Laconia which is
where asparta is based
and the word after all these years
actually means using very few words to
express yourself
and I like to use the same sort of
mindset for logging
because the way I like to think about
logging is I want to be accurate
descriptive
and short I don't want it to be lacking
information I want the same information
but with less fluff tell me what
happened tell me what happened now so I
can act on it
I want to have consistent name
parameters across my whole system not
just the application the system is going
to make your life so much easier
debugging issues
and I want to utilize my log levels
properly so I don't have too much
chatter in my logs
so in the final rule for me is rule
number eight
I should only log what's necessary to
tell a good story
thank you very much and keep coding
[Applause]